Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. This is the clustered series. Today, we
are gonna be taking two broken Kubernetes clusters
and live debugging and hopefully
fixing them.
I am not smart enough to do this
alone, so I am joined by a wonderful
guest. Today, I'm joined by Lee Briggs, a
developer and developer advocate
at Pulumi Corp, and
the very first breaker.
Hey, Lee.
Hey. Thanks for having me. It's really exciting
to be here. I've watched all the other
episodes. I think I did the first cluster.
You did. You broke the very first cluster.
And I was kind, and I just edited
a config map. And it looks like since
then, things have escalated fairly significantly. So,
yeah, prior to being a developer and developer
advocate,
I was
building out Kubernetes platforms
from scratch and have
built them before EKS and and all those
kind of things were things. So it's but
it's been a while, and I'm excited to
see if I still have all of that
knowledge and memory there or if I'm gonna
be any used to it all used to
you at all.
Well, you you will. I think, you know,
based on my experience of having three of
these under me, like,
you just you forget how to think in
a weird way. Right? And having having a
guest here and being able to talk about
what's actually happening will slow us down.
Hopefully, not get us down too many rabbit
holes, but, you know, it's
it's tough. And as you can see from
the comments, everybody is so supportive. They're all
on our side.
I know. This feels it feels like collective
shard and frog at this point. Everyone's just
really enjoying our sense of doom and dread
as things go along.
And I've been on all three sides of
it now. So breaker,
observer, and now fixer. So this
is gonna be exciting. And I also will
say it's the first
at at least we're united Great Britain from
at this point as well. So
Yeah.
Well, I think
we just need to rip the band aid
off here. We need to get into the
first cluster.
Let's see what we're dealing with and then
take it from there. So this is
cluster zero zero seven. This was broken
by Matt Moore and Dan Paul.
We
should just get this on with
not looking forward to this one. Gotta be
on it.
So as always, we are well, as always,
as of, like, two whole episodes ago, we
are now using Teleport to aid us debugging
these clusters. Really cool tool. You should check
it out. It gives us access to each
of the nodes so we can try and
fix things together.
The superpower here is we have a shared
terminal
from David. See, I can't even type echo.
That's not a good start.
Lee, do you wanna just confirm with it?
There we go. Nice.
Okay. There we go.
So we've not looked at anything yet. We
don't know what state this cluster is in.
We don't know if we have an API
server. We don't know well, we don't know
anything. So I usually like to start just
by using the admin token and seeing if
we can get the nodes, get the pods
to get anything at this point,
and then we'll work out from there.
My personal preference if we go straight for
nodes, like,
kinda get an get an idea of if
yeah. Okay. There we go. Oh, it's it's
bigger, right, With no API. Yeah. Yeah. Excellent.
It's getting all far too familiar with this.
Okay.
I wish I could say it gets easier.
I think that it gets worse. It definitely
gets worse.
Okay. What do you think? What do wanna
look at first? Six nine six nine looks
like a weird port.
So I think running Docker PS
would be a good start. Make sure the
actual
oh, sorry. Contain use Containerd.
We do use Containerd. Actually
check that Containerd is running
the control plane pods would be probably a
good start and see what part they are
on,
and then go from there is was probably
what my first thought is. Well, that's one
of those things I've never actually bothered to
look up. There is a cry control, but
it doesn't do anything without configuration. And I've
never actually got it.
Weird bug in Teleport where I have to
relook my page randomly or it doesn't scroll.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have to fail that as an
issue. It should be a good old source
citizen.
So if we don't control pods,
it never works. It never points to the
right socket. I know Walid has just commented
saying run that command. If you remember what
the flag is to point it to the
socket, drop it in the chat and I'll
use it. However, I think you're rightly.
That's not the right port. Yes.
So let's just
sorry. There you go.
No. That I I we basically need to
get an idea of if the control plane
is running at this point, and
old old school would be docker p s
and actually
check if the actual containers are running.
And because, obviously, the port could have changed
in the
admin.com,
but
they might also not be running as well.
So
I I with container d, I'm not entirely
sure how you would run p s. I
Oh, I've just tried to p s to
look at every process on this host, and
there's nothing that resembles an API server. Excellent.
Okay. So is the Kubelet running?
We have
a Kube controller manager.
That's it.
Cool.
System CTL
status Kubelet would be probably a good start.
Sorry. Say that again? Oh, yeah. Just check
yeah. System CTL status Kubelet and see if
that is running.
It is.
But it looks like there's a bunch of
logs there, and, obviously, it can't connect to
That's weird.
I never saw Kubelet.
Oh, I rang okay. I rang Kubernetes. That
was my mistake. Okay.
No.
Why? Where's my oh, no. That is okay.
Yeah. We've got a we've
got a kubelet. We've got a kubelet control
manager. Okay. So the kubelet is running,
which means it should be starting the static
manifest,
which run the API server, the scheduler, and
the controller manager. In the ETC I'm guessing
they're in ETC Kubernetes
at this point.
Yep. This should be in this directory here.
Okay.
We do have an API server, but it
is not running. So let's
let's scan this. And I'm really bad for
this. I keep flying through these and messing
stuff and the audience. I just used it.
There we go. Thanks, Dan.
Alright.
Yeah. I'm really bad for skimming through these
two quickly. So I'm gonna slow myself down.
We can see
if you ask server, the advertised address looks
like it might be alright.
See, let me know if you see anything
that looks fishy.
I'd look looks all looks good to me
so far.
I wonder if it's just the port in
the cube config.
Yeah. We might be well, I think I
think we might be getting there. Let's we
should probably fix that first, and it it
it should be 6334,
I think.
So it's 443, not 334. There we go.
Make sure there's no more.
Yeah. Okay.
So keep config.
Probably gonna have to restart the cubelet, I
think.
Oh, no. Because we only modified the we
didn't modify the Oh, yeah. Yeah. We just
modified the config. So I did try and
speak to this here. But, of course, we
do know that by running PS, we didn't
have an API server either. So we're gonna
need to work out
where our API server is. Now
the manifest is here. It
didn't get started.
I guess we wanna start looking at would
you say the cubelet logs? Maybe where we
wanna head next? Yeah. Yeah. The the cubelet
logs seems like a journal CTL on the
cubelet logs. I think it's just gonna tell
us the the cubelet can't connect to the
API server
more than likely.
Okay.
Kubelet.
No pager.
And if I can remember, is it
since fifteen minute.
That only works. Right?
Alright. Guess not. I mean, I'd less. Just
dump the whole thing.
I see a crash loop back off.
My screen is definitely locked up.
Oh, okay. Yeah. We do have a crash
loop back off.
Something reference in Cilium.
Yeah. I may have to refresh this tab.
Well, it's not happening.
Yeah. It's crashed. Okay.
Yeah. I'm I'm not getting any scroll back
in Teleport at this point. So
Alright. Let's go to the
firewall containers.
Let's see what's recent.
Where's the API server?
Oh, there it is. Okay.
Cube API server.
There we go. There we go. That looks
pretty
always and we're gonna have to regenerate all
the certificates.
No. If anyone's been that harsh, they're getting
a swift
kick the first time I see them. I'm
hoping
I just I I
handling keys is is an absolute nightmare.
I'm hoping it's just
Oh, yeah. API server dot turd.
How wonderfully juvenile.
But we already had the port six nine
six today. Know. Right? I yeah. There's a
theme generator. There's a theme going on here.
I I think we're definitely gonna have to
restart the keyword at this point.
Yeah. Let's do that.
Okay. So
our API server wasn't available. We have seen
the error from the viral
our log containers directory. We've restarted the kubelet,
fixed that file.
Hopefully,
we
have an API server. Not not We do
not.
And let's just see if we get any
additional logs from QB API server.
Not yet. So it's maybe just not restarted
yet. I had this weird issue last week
as well to be honest. And I think
the solution was
to move
the API server
out
and bracket.
Let's see where that gets us.
When was that? That was a few minutes
ago. I guess we can just wait.
We should maybe we can I I know
the cubit logs are? Let me have a
look at what the general CTN come up.
So general CTL command is for follow. So
Matt's comment is saying, at least there's only
one control plane node this time. Yes. Have
learned that I learned that lesson.
Nobody wants to see me replicate the same
fix across the different machine.
I think we can do
minus
u
kubelet.
Office file or directory.
Oh, the kubelet binary is gone.
Is that is that right?
Is this can you wanna It looks like
it. A wedge on user Ben Kubelet?
Now
if if I if if I'm gonna learn
anything from what we've seen so far, this
is gonna have an interesting name.
My l s minus a l
user
in
crap.
Sorry.
Nope.
Yeah. May just If you deleted it altogether,
we might have to download it.
Don't you try l a dash l h
t, which should sort it by that sort
by time, and then we can just see
what was changed recently.
Yes. Go
ahead on that so we see the first.
Yeah.
Oh, no. That
that's not working at all.
I think it's just been removed. I mean,
there's every possibility here it's just been completely
deleted.
Oh, wrong directory.
Which, by the way, is real really mean
because
the cubelet was running,
and it obviously, the binary is
being used by system d, and so it's
been removed.
And as soon as we restarted it, we're
now in a worse position than when we
started,
which is just really mean.
So I think what we're probably
going to have to do
how does your setup install the cubelet? You
know when I
something
I'm gonna take a shot in the dark
here. No. When I did the when I
moved to manifest this last time, I didn't
Oh, wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Somebody in the chat just said it's it's
there. They've renamed it to Pubelet.
Yeah. Look. It's the third line up here.
So let's do
Bash history is off limits, I'm afraid. Nice
idea though, but we do have a a
an agreement. So
Okay. So now we should be able
to start this. How does everybody see that?
That see, it's the blinkers have just been
here. That's what it is. Yeah. I think
yeah.
So then
let's see. T l status.
Kubla is running now.
Is it it's loaded.
Is it running?
No. I don't think it's running.
What what are the permissions
on?
Alright.
Just give a wee wee nudge here.
What
happens if you're on a PS and correct
for triplet, is it?
Alright.
You can just do a system control start
to play. Maybe it's just not enabled or
something, or is it failing? It's exited.
What next?
Oh, we're getting a stack trace from API
machine. That's not a good that's not a
good start.
Do you wanna
let's run this through.
No pager.
And then put it through in there. We've
got
At the top there. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So
we need to go to viral load kubelet.
I'll I'll let you do the the tape
in just now.
What did it say? Look at the permissions
on that config. Well
Oh, excellent.
I think this is the the cat and
mouse cluster. Thanks, Matt and Dan.
Is it I'm wondering if they've set ATR
on this or something. So I'm gonna try
this with not the
okay.
At least they haven't set ATR on it.
That's that's a good start.
Let's give this let's give it a restart
now and see if that's happy now. Well,
I mean, I'm gonna be
don't try this at home, folks.
I'm gonna do that.
No. No. That's not about it. That's not
a good idea. Let's do 644.
There's no judgment on this show, mate. What's
that? 777.
I just wanna get it started. We can,
like I mean, this is a production incident.
Said no judgment, and then you take service
cubes that restart like an absolute I know.
I'm old school, so
Alright.
Let's get It's not quite there. Yep.
Four seconds ago, auto restart. Not being good.
Alright. I've keep the config.
No such file or directory.
Oh, wait. That's probably old.
Oh, is that a different error?
Looking
Oh, no. This is this is the March
9. Right. Yeah. This is this is a
long time ago. Let's
I wonder why my since fifteen minutes didn't
work. Anyone in the chat remember what the
time parameter is on journal journal CTL?
Yeah. Let's see. It's there's so many logs
that Teleport can handle the
scroll back. So I think I've just crashed
my session.
Alright.
Let's just reload.
That's just quite okay. Yeah. We need to
be careful with that.
Okay. So journal
c t l dash u dash
dash tail.
I yeah. I usually use follow, which will
give you, like, minus f, which will give
you, like, real time streaming at least.
But I don't think we could scroll back
up with that, can we? No.
Okay. I need to remember what the syntax
is.
I guess you could Is it?
You could bust out the man page.
Woah.
Dash. Yeah. Oh, there we go. Thanks, Matt.
So what's that? General C T L Dash
U Q Dash
N
Okay.
Need no pager on that too, actually. Otherwise,
I don't know if need to read that.
Is it a political opinion if we start
talking about system d in general t t
CTL at this point?
Yeah. Go for it. It's all good.
And this is all easier when you could
just tailhog files, in my opinion. I like
h Come
on.
No need to bring the Scottish roots into
this. So the green Alright.
We we need to go modify the
duplicate configuration.
So d d r lib.
Definitely a cat in this episode.
Hagas.
Lovely.
What's our CEO's goal?
I'd like to just take a moment to
say everybody on the chat who hasn't tried
Haggis is delicious, and you should definitely
go out of your way to try it.
Yeah. I guess it's amazing.
C a dot p s there. I don't
even know what one we need. C a
dot s there, isn't it?
Give that a second.
Oh, it's minus five minutes. Is that right?
No.
Just drop that.
If that works, I'll be so happy. I
knew it was cool.
There we go. Perfect. Thank you, Noel.
Alright.
As discussed, I'm crying. No. I'm not crying.
Thank you.
Activate. Look
at that.
So let's check if our API server is
running now.
Oh.
No.
So we at least we got the Kubelet
running. Oh, did we move the manifest back?
Yes. Yes. We did. Alright. So I'm gonna
change that. Oh, you can jump into the
firewall containers
firewall containers.
Oh, yeah. Tail the API server. Well, log
containers.
Tail
at c d.
Anyway, I I can't remember anybody breaking the,
at c d setup yet, so maybe we're
gonna get lucky today.
Yeah. You wanna tilt the API server so
we can see why it's not starting?
Oh, that's what I thought. Oh, no. I
did the control plane. My bad.
A cube dash API. Just tilt that.
Oh, sorry. Yeah. My bad.
Alright.
Livestream bunkers. It's tough.
More PKI changes.
Alright. It's just changed in the context, so
we need to change it back to be
API server -kubelet-client.crt
instead of .pop.
S yeah. As in the bar lab kubelet
config dot yaml.
Oh, sorry. Yeah. Barlib
kubelet
config.
Carlos is asking who broke this cluster.
It is Matt and
Dan Pop,
former friends of mine.
It's not in there. Okay. So that means
it might be in
wherever that be configured. Oh, the static manifest
perhaps. Yeah. I thought what my
yeah. That was that. Yep. Hop is there.
Oh, goddamn it.
I've got my VIM config. I feel completely
You want me to do it? Yes, please.
I'm completely useless without my ID at this
point. I feel so
there we go.
Okay.
Now because we've changed the manifest, let's just
give it that we've I mean, I usually
find that just kicking the cube load will
will be enough, I think.
Well, it's gonna restart I mean, because it's
a static manifest, it's gonna try to there
we go. It's gonna try to restart it
in a few seconds.
Alright. I'll let you take it. Do wanna
see if can get get notes on this
thing? Kubel I can't remember the magic incantation.
I know. Kubectl
dash dash kubectl.
Oh, yeah. Sorry. Yeah.
Kubectl. Kubectl.
I've been get nodes.
Post is Kube config.
Oh, yes. Sorry. Yep.
That's
it. Oh, wait. What? The the nodes aren't
joined though.
But we should be able to get the
pods,
and it should
okay.
That's interesting.
I was kinda hoping that was us.
Hoping that was a fix.
Right. Okay. So
none of our nodes are connected. Although the
API server wasn't running. Let's give that a
minute because the other machines are gonna have
to
jump back in,
get connected.
And the API server not running means we
actually probably wouldn't be able to run a
bit pods anyway and open that are running.
You wanna do a PSC UX and correct
for
a core DNS?
Let's
have a look at the API server logs
while we're in this directory.
Queue API server.
Matt has said, welcome to phase two.
Minus n. Let's do a hundred.
Storage error. Key enough. Oh, now we're in
now they have they have screwed this as
a CD. That looks things.
I don't maybe I need to refresh. I
I don't think I'm good.
So I don't know.
Unable to remove old endpoints from Kubernetes service.
Key not
found.
Okay. Yeah. So this is at CD, I
think. This is the
I believe.
Okay. So let's let's think this through. Let's
get nodes. It's not returning even this local
node.
Yep.
We have a QUI run. So the a
the API server, the process is running, but
it's still not healthy.
Like, it's still not started up correctly,
and it's probably
not actually responding to all of the nodes
that are trying to connect is is what
I'm seeing at the moment.
So
the
the API server
logs that we're seeing here I don't know
if you can see this in
I don't know if you can see that
in
your teleport session,
but there is a log entry that is
telling us when it's the well, when the
API server is trying to connect to,
can't remember if it's a controller manager or
at CD.
But the there's something wrong, basically. So Kubernetes
manifest
cube API
server.
Yeah. So we're connecting to the local at
c d here, and I think the local
at c d has been
Wanna check it's running? I don't think we've
looked for that in a p s command.
I accidentally
looked for it earlier. But
yes. So it is running. It's not That's
the p s server. Okay. So our static
manifest for SCD is parked as well. Oh,
god. Yeah. Also we
also don't have cube scheduler running, so we're
gonna need to fix that too.
Okay. So let's go back into the static
manifest directory.
Vim, etcd,
Kubernetes,
manifest,
etcd.
Okay. Let's see.
This set your
mean, my skin is that there's nothing modified.
So it could just be the schedule. Don't
know if it's static manifest.
Wonder if there's anything in the
CD
log here.
I'll state as okay,
but That's that's right now.
That's that's, like, two seconds ago.
Maybe it's just got off the scroll. Am
I not seeing it? Oh, it is running.
Okay.
I think our scrolls are maybe different.
There is an entity there. There's a recent
Yeah. It's that. It's yeah. It is running.
I don't think so.
I have to refresh.
Oh, no. It's not a scroll. You're alright.
Okay.
Let's do
yeah. It's running. Is that five minutes?
No. March time. Okay. SCD is okay. Sorry.
I'm SCD is running by the looks of
things.
Okay. Let's go work it by the schedule.
The schedule is not running.
And
then we'll come back to the API the
the notes not being registered.
That way, I'll I want the whole control
plane online before I start debugging on. Yeah.
Yeah. I I agree. I agree.
So
We got a few comments.
Scotland sucks.
Well, he says, no distractions
and mission weapons. Yeah. I mean, definitely stuff
we need to look at.
Carlos.
Yep. Think about life cycle to register node.
And Matt has given us a little bit
of confidence. He thinks that the API should
be fine. So let's get the scheduler on
mine, and then we'll take it from there.
Hang on. Authorization
queue configs.
That certainly seems better.
Before we even
before we even try and get the scheduler
back online, let's look at the control manager,
which
I think when we were doing our earlier
PSs, they were all fine anyway. So
Yeah. I just gotta scan, sir. Come on.
Qubel's running. API server is running. Hang on.
At CD, API server,
Qubeler.
Still no sign of the other ones.
Scala.
Cannot open. Oh, wait. I'm logged on to
you. Yeah.
Oh, yeah. It's coming. Okay. That looks better.
Not like you know history, Rule. I feel
like that I would definitely be logging in
and being like, what did I do earlier
that I've forgotten?
Well, I think they have forgotten. I mean,
even Matt was like, oh, yeah. Get
notes.
Still no notes.
Run a PS. Can we see the scheduler?
Just grab for scheduler, I guess.
Alright. Okay. Cool. Yep. Okay. So now we
have to work out the what's going on.
Let's look at the API server logs again.
I don't know if that actually use a
red heading or not. Maybe Matt or Dan,
if you wanna drop a comment before we
start going down the wrong path here. And
now now we're into Oh, there we go.
Validation web. We have web. Yeah. So okay.
So
we're getting there at least.
So how maybe I mean, it's been a
year since I've done this. How would you
specify a
validation webhook
statically
with the
We can check. So it it depends if
it's dynamic or not. So oops. Sorry. Do
you mind if I type? Yeah. Go for
it. Yeah. So it could be that they
have added a web hook on the API
server manifest.
I guess the the API server is now
responding, so we should probably be able to
do get validating web hooks. Right?
Depends how the In theory? Yeah. It might
be it depends if it's a dynamic admission
controller or if it is here. But you
can see we've got this node restriction here.
Enable admission plugins.
So I'm gonna There we go.
We'll let that restart the API server, and
we should be able to have our notes
register.
Doesn't feel like it doesn't feel great to
sit here and cross your fingers, does it?
Like
I'm sorry. Oh, go ahead. You do you
do the you do the queue control. I
just wanted to check if we got a
restart on this. Yeah. Yeah. No. Not yet.
Did we make it worse? We made it
worse.
I wonder if I can't remove that flag
just wildly with that. So
API.
Hasn't auto completed properly, I don't think. Yeah.
Dot log. There we are.
Which one do I want? F f or
c?
Pass.
The newest one.
Quota admission.
We don't have a node validation
anymore. Did I not just remove it?
Okay. There's the API server.
Let's see what happens with
should set this up beforehand so people don't
need to keep watching me do it. I
have an alias and and locally as well.
So yeah.
Alright. Can you can you get
can you get the admission controls?
Yeah. Validating
webhooks.
And just do dash dash all name. Admission.
I can't remember the actual name.
No. Me neither. This is when Google call
Yeah. Resources. Yeah. Oh, what was that again?
Q c t l API dash resources. Oh,
yeah. It's not get, is it? It's just
that. Yeah.
And grab for
validating.
Okay.
So now we wanna do a key get,
And we just delete that.
Can we do all net before you do
that, can we do all namespaces?
I don't think they're I don't think these
are namespaced, but yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. They are global, aren't
they? Yeah. Okay.
Well, I wouldn't delete it. Let's have a
look at it first, see what they're doing.
Like because if we have to get if
we have to get it back manually,
I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to do that.
Yeah. I think this is this just needs
to delete these.
Well,
I I think another a better way, think,
is to remove the resources. So,
again, like
I'm thinking yeah. If we if
you make that an if you make that
an empty array,
I think that might be
yeah.
Nope.
They didn't.
Is that immutable?
Oh, no. Required field. Just
maybe foo as a resource as one array
because that's not a valid resource. Right? Webhook
rules resources as required.
It's there.
But it's I think it's empty. So if
we I think you might be right. We
might have to just delete it.
We could just do oh, hold on.
Yeah.
Cool. There we go. You wanna you wanna
try to get notes?
No. Is Noah a valid answer? There we
go.
Nice.
Okay. So those are two. Like, worker notes
I was expect I'm hoping that maybe not
changed anything on the workers. They should come
back online
now that the registration should be alright.
Yeah. That won't work with the alias. But
you can just do key get notes dash
w.
I don't like the output.
There we go. Okay. That's good.
Alright.
Let's see what the comments are seeing.
I think people are agreeing with it.
Nice.
I do think we we can wait for
the WorkerNodes to register, but I do think
it might be the case they have messed
with those as well. Maybe I'm being very
cynical. So
we might wanna switch to a
WorkerNode and see what the life cycle looks
like on there.
Yeah. Alright. Let's go. Let's
I'll be I'm connecting to first worker on
the list, JBW7V.
Yeah. I have to see the active session,
so I'll join that. Okay.
Oh, there won't be a cube admin on
this. Only way I'd be able to do
it locally. Okay. We can just check the
basics then. So we expect to see
A cube look. A cube look running here.
K. That's a good sign. Let's just restart
it and see if it helps speed up
the joining process.
And if I really quickly pop back.
Journal.
No. We I'll look. Do we come back?
No.
It's registered. It's still not ready. Okay. I
think I guess, actually, probably
I think we should kick all the other
ones real quick
and make sure they all join. And then
I would feel pretty okay
once the once this working order's has joined.
I have I received your
call.
We should also check our workloads are running
through.
K.
Well, WordPress
is still pending.
Let me describe it. Describe
your NGINX.
We've changed the max port limit.
Yeah. I can't remember where that is. If
you know where it is, then please feel
free to take over.
It's in the controller manager, I think.
Where'd
you set the max plot limit again?
I think I think controller the scheduler, sorry,
not the controller manager, which seems
Kubernetes manifests.
Kubernetes
scheduler.
Nope. What's the port number on that?
Zito?
Isn't that
I think that's valid. That I seem to
remember that being valid. Yeah. I believe so.
Let's see what else we got.
Yeah. Port zero again. Maybe that's just a
red heading.
I'm gonna just look it up. Kubernetes.
Oh, wait. We're looking at the wrong node.
We're looking at the control plane. The cubelet
on the actual
node is probably where the Macs pods are
set.
Alright. Let's jump onto the first one again.
Because this obviously isn't gonna get scheduled on
the control plane.
So the cubelet config on here is probably
Weird bug. Alright. Okay.
Let's
see.
Yeah. Let's just Google it. It could be
on it could be on the unit file
if you wanna check there.
On the system to go unit file?
Not much help.
It might be in this environment. I mean,
it could be a set in as environment
variable, I guess. Do you wanna quickly lock
it up look it up while
see where else it could be set while
I just randomly type command and hope it
gets fixed.
Oh, I'm in the control plane mode. Yeah.
So did you look at the unit file?
I did. Sorry. I looked on the
I I didn't realize we were on the
back on the
master node. Sorry. The controller node.
Alright. I'm drawing a blank.
Well, I mean, they definitely they definitely have
set a max number of nodes.
It's just figuring out where it's actually been
where where, like, where all the possible places
that it's been set.
So the capacity is a 10 on our
first worker node. So I did a describe
on that node.
I'm on the control plane again. Sorry.
Oh, we just have a no schedule uninitialized
on this. I'm gonna remove that team.
I don't even know if that was them
or if that's our CCM.
Wait.
Do we remember earlier on there was a
log message about Cilium? Did we haven't actually
looked to all of the
cube system, like,
the pods to make sure they're all scheduled
correctly.
I'm gonna remove this 10 anyway just to
see what happens. Yeah.
And then I would do k get pods
minus
yeah.
Woah.
Okay. Some stuff's running.
I'm gonna add all of those notes.
I'm just gonna remove that.
I'll just do it from now. 10.
Think confused about why they're approach.
I I I I'm a bit confused why
they aren't registering. Like, it is the
is the CNI
initialized?
Okay.
So we have got a pod. See,
almost?
Well, I mean, maybe we could I think
we just need to kill these pods and
have oh, no. Because we already ran around
that NGINX container and that didn't get scheduled,
did it?
Okay. Matt, Dan, you're in the chat. Have
we fixed everything that you've broken and this
is an unrelated error? Or is this still
part of your phase two? We're gonna allocate
a few more minutes to it before we
move on to our second cluster.
Greatly. There
are some pending
Cilium
pods here.
Somebody in the chat said allocatable
we must have missed this. The allocatable CPU
is only 10 m,
and I think we were just kind of
scrolling
past a lot of stuff because we
Allocatable CPU. Where is that setting, Liv?
On the worker? I think it
think it might be on the worker. Yes.
Okay.
Within the flag.
Alright. Let's use the control plane. Right? This
is what this is good at. So get
nodes, describe nodes,
whatever workers.
Right? And someone in the chat suggested that
allocatable CPU is small.
Yeah. Look. See, the request the CPU requests
are a %.
But I think that's just the number of
calls. Right?
I'm probably reading.
Invalid capacity is zero on image fail system.
Something wrong with our disk.
I
don't know if that's we can done the
wrong path again or not, though.
Well, let's let's describe the node.
Let's describe the node. Yeah. And then
Oh, yeah. Allocatable CPU 10 m.
Okay.
So where do we change this?
Is that just under just as a node.
Right?
Yeah. Yeah. I think so.
Okay.
Delete.
Wait. That's the you're removing that from the
status, so I don't think that's gonna matter
anyway. I'm removing it from everywhere. Yeah.
Okay.
Let's describe our notes
and see if that is gone.
No. It's still there.
So this must be a set and provided
somewhere.
Oh, all y'all. Sorry.
That was my fault. I started typing.
Oh, you're allowed to type. I'm the one
that shouldn't be allowed to type.
Okay. How do we fix this? I'm gonna
Google it.
You can if you wanna click the
Yeah. I'm just gonna look at the notes.
Interesting.
K. There's flags on the cube lit cube
reserves
that we should probably go check out. So
we're gonna wanna check the system to unit
file, the kubelet flag, the kubelet flags, and
So what we're looking for? Sorry.
Well, I think we need to go on
a worker note.
Look at the cubel configuration.
There's nothing in this file. Right?
Doesn't look like it.
I'm almost stuck in them.
Okay. Your flag.
I didn't I didn't see anything there. That
would be confusing. By the way, Matt and
Dan are saying that they I'm not ready
to give up yet. So
I don't wanna know the answer yet. We're
I feel like we're close. And Let's check
the defaults.
Is there anything here?
No. Alright.
Status.
Okay.
Everything we need to know is in this
unit fail. Everything I think. So I'm just
gonna
cat it.
Nope. Not that one. Where's the other one?
I just do if you just do system
CTL cat, it will show you the if
you do system CTL,
it shows you, like, all of the drop
ins and then rendered, like, the the full
actual
yeah. So the environment file is empty. The
sorry. The second ETC default environment file is
empty.
The environment file, the cube ADM flags dot
env isn't
there.
Sorry. Isn't didn't have anything in it.
I wonder if the set look at the
bottom. Right? We've got, like are these environment
variables? Could they be provided? No. They have
to come from environment files, don't they? So
Oops. Alright.
I can smell it.
I
We must be staring right at it. That's
the thing. I think we probably are.
I'm in the KubeConfig.
We checked that fail.
Oh, wait. There's the could
be an etcetera Kubernetes KubeConfig or etcetera Kubernetes
Bitstrap KubeConfig. Let's go check those.
Come back on it.
So that one
doesn't that's what put That one doesn't exist.
I think we looked at that. Yeah. That's
just I can't modify that. That's just the
that's just to connect to the API server.
Yeah. Alright.
I'm gonna try Varlib kuplit.
Well, it says slash e t C slash
default kuplet. I did look there. I didn't
see a kuplet. Yeah. That's it. It doesn't
even it doesn't even exist, I don't think.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's not even there. Look. No. It's
jessie ten dash people dot com. I'm not
sure where you've seen that.
Oh,
that's the
see, look, this is right here. That's the
drop in file that is like, the system
CTL cat, like, concatenate it altogether.
I feel like we're so close.
I'm not I'm not ready to give up
yet. Like
I think this is hiding stuff from us.
Can we open that 10qbdm.com?
Because it's going off the screen and I
think I think there's a flag on the
end of it.
So it's a system b system. Yeah.
What's an I'm gonna wrap it here though.
Where is the hiddenness?
I almost want to
general
CTL manage you, Kubla, ISF.
All that stuff. We've we've spent too much
time on this cluster.
Feel free, anyone. Let's tell us where the
status is because
we've checked everywhere I can think of except
maybe in just the, like, a set of
profile.
Yeah. If I added anything in there. Okay.
That was a cool command. I like that
cat thing.
I wasn't aware of that.
I always end up just trying to find
the unit tail and then say the getting
confused.
If
you actually did that, Matt, that would have
been hilarious.
I bet you set up an alias in
the actual system configuration, which won't be loaded
by Teleport. But they tried to replace them
with Emacs.
Oh, horrible piece.
Oh,
we haven't looked at the mutating webhook.
that's so mean.
That's the workers, so you have to go
back to the
control plane.
And it's mutating webhoc. You put yeah.
I'm
lost without my auto complete.
There's a defaulting on it.
Dot k s I o.
Look at that. That's so I actually didn't
know you could do that. That's relatively new.
So
it's
if you I think, again, if we change
the resources to foo
like this
not actually sure what this is doing. Modifying.
Right?
Side effects, none? Oh, no. It's calling this
external URL, which is the new mutation.
So they're setting up in their own thing.
I want I really wanna just see what
this is.
Yeah. You need to pass it on body
and stuff. Alright.
That's good. I like that.
Bastard.
So
it looks like they're modifying
the mutating webhook is modifying the node as
it joins the API server to
mutate
the available resources. Am I right in what
you had done there?
Yeah. They've added that mutating webhook. It's called
a third party external URL,
and they're writing in that weird stuff too.
That's that's good. I always forget to check
the admission controllers. I really need to get
into better habits.
Alright. So let's look at our pods. Of
course, it runs on. There we go. Look.
Do want me say k native or native,
Matt?
It's such a powerful it's a such a
powerful part of Kubernetes that you can basically
modify any resource as it kind of turns
up in the API server.
Like, if,
you know, if your Kubernetes cluster was to
be,
like, attacked for some reason, like, you basically
will be chasing,
you know, chasing things forever.
If you can host your own URL as
well, that's feels pretty pretty powerful.
Alright. I am calling this one fixed. Good
job, Lee and the audience.
Let's get on to our second cluster.
Is it too early to have a drink
at 10AM? I think I'm starting to feel
like I might need one.
Yeah. I'm not far. I'm I'm not far
in my my victory beer. But
oh, come forward. Yeah.
My losing beer. Consolation beer. Right. Okay. Our
second cluster is
broken by Akash
at puck on Twitter.
I guess we're just going to the exact
same thing again and
Did
you set up the alias here just in
so that in case I yeah. K
Get notes.
Nope.
Oh, god. I can't remember the syntax. Did
you join your own session?
Oh, no. I think I I think I
joined the one we set up earlier. So
hold on. Let me get into that one.
Alright. Okay. No. It's okay. I'll join that
one. It's fine.
Oh, no. No. No. I've closed it now.
I
need to I need to I need to
close it down again. So if you set
sign up a session, I'll join it now.
Okay. I'm in a session. We have our
alias.
I am unable to run get nodes. Excellent.
I'll be with you any minute now.
Your colleague Paul has said it's never too
early. It's 6PM.
Okay.
From
our breakers as well. You know what
Okay. That's timing out. I'm
not sure what's going on there. So I'm
gonna let you drive. Let's just do the
pulse
check on all the control plane components and
see where we are.
And so it's running.
API server's running. Control amount just running. Queue
proxy's running. Queue bot's running.
Let's check.
The Kubelet is actually
healthy.
I have a theory that I don't want
to share just yet.
Okay. So we're getting RPC errors as it's
trying to connect to the
trying to connect to the API server.
I
wonder
oh,
and, yes, I don't know what the
there we go.
Has
have we
had somebody
mess with the IP tables changed? Reload it.
It's gonna not be scrolling thing. There we
go.
So you think it's an IP So when
you re no.
I was just making sure that, like, there
was no
because the cubelet's trying to connect to the
API server at the moment, and it can't,
and it's, like, timing out even.
And we're getting a lot of if you
look at the errors here, we're getting a
lot of
RPC errors.
And my my theory was that there was
like, we've we've rejected all the traffic, but
I think that was a poor theory at
this point.
Okay. But we do have an API server
running. Right? We've seen that on a previous
test. Okay.
Interesting.
Can we curl a Con whatever?
Wanna drive that? I think it you probably
want the IP address and then health z
or something like that to make sure it's
or you could just cheat and That
what we need is here.
So advertise address.
URL.
H t p.
This is why I shouldn't drive. Okay. HTTPS
at 22
secure.
K. Yeah. Healthy.
Many requests.
Okay. So
Akash has confirmed the IP tables was not
touched. Thank fuck. Seriously.
Okay.
So if the
API server is unhealthy
for some reason,
what could
have caused that?
Nothing wrong with drinking at 10AM, Carlos. You
enjoy. I think Leo will
I'm on vacation after this too. So
I thought I need, like, two weeks off
in order to get over this. So
Okay. So we got too many requests. So
the
we need to work out why it's rejected.
So you have just pulled up the is
this the API server manifest?
Yes. Okay.
And I'm just seeing trying to see if
we have restricted
the
allocations to this, and it doesn't look like
it. But that and that's not even the
right place to look because it would be
in the queue, but I think, wouldn't it?
But the API server is rejecting
our curl. So something wrong with API server.
My but the too many requests is
probably the the pod that's running probably has
a limited number of
actual
OS allocation.
I don't think that's the right way of
phrasing it. Could you are you following along
with what I'm trying to say? Like No.
So the the web the API web server
is, like has got allocations at the pod
level, like actual operating system allocations of, like,
CPU cycles and memory and all that kind
of stuff. And even just a standard control
plane with, like, a nodes and a few
pods is is basically overwhelming the API server
because the like, it that there's it's serving
too many requests is
what I think this is saying.
So my
working theory is that
we've restricted the allocations at the pod level
to,
you know, give it only 10 megabytes of
memory or something silly like that.
I could be way off,
but that's what I'm
currently
thinking.
Okay.
Can we not check that from the proc
file system,
I think? Yes. And you're gonna you're gonna
have to drive that because I am
out of out of touch with the
the If we just grab the process number,
the process
speaker.
What
we got? There's a way to see that
kind of stuff. If it was at a
secret level, we should be able to kinda
get something from here.
Too long. Okay. Limit.
That throws my theory out of the window
then. Yeah. I think that's that's fine. So
let's go back to the manifest.
What do we got here? Right? We got
our entity.
Oh, the timestamps and none of that has
changed. So there goes that plan. Right.
Yeah.
What about valid
Cubelet?
I just wanna see if the
API server
did we look at these yet?
Not yet.
No. Wait. You just look at this. I
think you pulled these up, didn't you? Alright.
Okay.
Alright. So you want to go to
Device plug in, pods, pod resources.
I don't know where those directories are.
Interesting.
Man, the old cluster, know. So I remember
seeing those before.
I have no idea. I don't think.
Okay.
I David.
I don't even know where to start with
the too many requesting, to be quite honest.
Like,
it's not it's not very promising.
What's our symptom again? Can't hit the API
server. And your hypothesis API server's API server's
overwhelmed.
It's serving summary. I guess what we could
probably do is just restart the cube load
here.
I mean, that's not goes into any trouble
at all yet, has it?
Has to be the API server. Let's run
gantlet. In fact, let's try that curl again.
Too many requests. Okay. Let's get some headers
out of this.
We're getting a four two nine. Boom. Mhmm.
Which is too many requests.
I just say, CTB code.
I just stated for my own sanity more
than anything else.
Did we modify the manifest?
I
don't know what's going on there.
Alright. When in doubt, API server
429.
Overloaded API server sends a 429.
We're not getting a lot of
help from the audience on this one.
I'm just looking up CTR.
C
s.
A.
That's interesting. I would've expected that to list
something.
Certainly, I brought one of these courses, it
did.
No. So valid
sent me this command to fix that, which
I think is needed in these environments. So
if we do
crash CTL.
Yaml
and drop in this path,
think
no, okay.
Didn't quite work.
Well, he says he wants to see the
logs on the API server. So let's
let's do that.
Queue API server.
Wish I had monitoring on these machines.
I need my time
series.
Why don't you just open that in VEM?
A log file? Yeah.
Let's just Alright.
So that started
okay. That's when I spun up the machine.
So let's just shift g right down to
the bottom. Like, I haven't
seen the actual error yet. Right?
Alright. Just gonna scroll up very quickly. I'm
looking for
my pattern matching.
I wonder if etcd
is
been messed with, and that's why the API
server is saying too many requests.
Because the API server connects to etcd,
and if
it can't write to etcd for some reason
or
Well, you'd suggest is there some for runtime?
I I don't see it. Let's go down.
Let's assume your theory is maybe right then.
So let's confirm HCD
is
healthy
or at least running.
We never actually checked. We only did the
oh, we we I I think we did
see it earlier,
and this should be a health endpoint.
I think it is. Nested cheat sheet. I
can use it quickly to the health code.
But let's check if if you do a
p s and make sure it's running. Or
just curl if you want. Yeah.
Yeah. It's there. Okay.
And then
I think it's
l
k
l c.
I'd expect that to work.
I guess I could just do,
that's client URLs.
For etcd, we'd have to pass in the
certificate
the the key from there slash Oh, cost
reward.
Let's just get Kubernetes as you do. I
I just use this all the time. I
never remember the entity command.
That's what I
Are we on the right track, Akash? Like,
I'm pretty stumped here. I'll be quite honest.
Like,
I I I think
I
said it's SEB.
Can't remember.
HCD client. Cool.
Okay. So HCD is configured to work, and
it's timing
out. So there we go. So we need
to fix HCD.
Oh, I crashed I'm glad my Siri. SCD
is fine. SCD is fine. Not touched. Excellent.
This is great. So XCD is broken, though.
I cautious suggested we look at the kubelet
log file.
You feel like we've looked at this, and
it didn't help much?
How
did we
did we not
No. It looks like we checked the we
were too focused on the API server.
So it is running.
You wanna do just get the last few
hundred lanes
and see if we can pinpoint that error?
Okay. What we got?
A lot of errors is what we've got.
Like, a lot of errors.
See if I can get this to start.
I guess what we could do is just
restart it and then tailor as it comes
up so we don't have to go through
all the scroll back.
I feel like I'm committed now.
Let's Okay. Yeah. Let's let's restart the QPET
and then jump straight into the tail.
And if we need to, we can always
modify the unit file to have it not
restart.
K.
So it's starting up.
It's
connecting to it. Oh my god. That was
fast.
Lots of errors.
I'm scrolling. I'm scrolling. I'm scrolling. So many
errors.
If any Kubernetes developers are watching, can you
not, like, panic and give us a full
stack trace like this? That'd be great.
Oh, yep. I broke it. I scrolled off
the screen.
It's the error
scrolled off the screen,
and it's restarting.
So I'm going to
grab
5,000 of these. Put them into fail.
Okay.
I don't think I've even got the start
of it.
That looks different. Okay.
No. Not yet.
Just a wall of text.
It's just a complete stack trace
of all of the
oh, wait. So this looks There we go.
There's stuff. Okay. Okay.
K.
Keep going.
I think it's because no NVIDIA devices were
found. Like, that was a log message that
seemed
relevant.
Keep going.
I guess that error that we've mentioned earlier,
and we never saw. But we've got a
unknown service runtime.
Failed to run kubelet. Failed to create kubelet.
Get remote runtime type version Okay. So something
that had wrong with container d.
Which we were on that track a a
little while back and then
got off that track.
Okay. So let's
let's do status,
the entity,
journal,
the entity.
There we go.
We never checked this. Like, we never we
never we just assumed this was running correctly.
This started
ten minutes ago.
Alright. Let's
That'll do it.
Sometimes it's a simple thing that we overcomplicate
it.
Alright. Let's see. K. Seven seconds ago.
So
I should be able to do
this now. Oh, wait. No. What is it?
Try control.
Pods?
Okay.
The container is fixed. I wonder if that
gets us back online. Do you wanna try
to get notes?
Alright.
Looks pretty good.
Akash is laughing at us. Okay. Yep. The
simple things, and he's also said that was
sorry. I assumed you'd But at least we
have an API we have an API server
now. So
I mean, there's a there's every chance this
has happened on all the working notes too.
But it looks like our control plane is
generally coming up
okay.
And,
like, once
our DNS comes up, we should be okay,
I'm guessing.
Well, Akash said there's a second problem, so
we'll need to try and see if we
can work that out. But let's yeah. Let's
see if we get core DNS. It doesn't
Do I describe that part? It's not
Where are these in where are these supposed
to get scheduled?
Well, if you just describe it, we'll see
if there's any conditions that are failing and
then
sorry.
Let's see.
No event.
Initialized but not ready.
Pod scheduled.
Nothing
obvious there. Can I run get pods again?
Okay. So we've got a we've got a
problem here. Okay.
We're on the control plane node. Core DNS
wouldn't be scheduled there. Should we go check
out the worker node?
I think that's a good plan.
Okay.
Let's assume they've made the same change.
These people hate us.
I'm just joining your session. Hold on. There
we go. Cool. Do you wanna grab the
what bottom marker v c and then just
fix the container d config and then we'll
see where we are.
Servers
connect.
Okay. So
And it was in cat e t c
container d. Yeah. Just delete I'll figure out
how it works.
K. So we've got we're working already now.
Third one, I'm assuming, is coming. Yeah.
I just restarted it, so it should be
up any minute now. Second.
And then we'll try and work out why
that core DNS isn't getting scheduled, and we'll
do it all under eight minutes.
Alright. Can't wait.
We
got some crash loop back offs on the
CNI,
which looks
interesting.
Right.
Okay.
So let's
you driving? I was gonna describe
I'll watch. Describe
PO.
Oh god. I've got something in my
in my
that is how you accidentally cause production outages,
everybody.
Exec in a container, no such file or
directory.
Cilium has that in a container that is
oh, wait.
Key get c m Cilium
minus o yaml.
We got to scroll past all of the
oh, wait. No. That's gonna be in the
pod definition. K. Get d s
cilium.
And if I upgraded the cluster to one
twenty one, we wouldn't see all that managed
fields. I need to remember that for next
time.
Okay.
So there's an init container.
And it looks like the command for the
init container has been edited to add a
forward slash to it.
Does
that does that look like the right thing
to you?
Hold on. Containers.
Containers. Where's in it?
Oh, there they are. Okay.
No. The slash in it dash container does
look okay. Do wanna copy the image name?
Let's let's oh, we don't have Docker.
Let's see. Let's just run it and poke
around. But
what was the error message again?
It said that the let's look at the
said that the it's trying to execute in
a container dot s h, and there's no
such file or directory.
Okay.
Just because my screen is shared, I'm gonna
copy that image name and run it locally
and take a look in the root directory.
You alright with that?
Yep. That's what works for me. Yep. Because
We got six minutes.
Easy. Alright.
Software container run dash dash r m dash
I t
overwrite the entry point.
Bash.
Assuming it's got bash in it.
Mean, normally, it's like entry point dot s
h in the root of the container. I'm
not familiar with the sodium one. So we're
just I think I should be there if
we just look at it.
It looks like
Akash is saying that
the first problem is not fixed. So Oh,
they followed up with as fixed, I think.
Right? Oh,
problem one is not really fit or is
really fixed.
Why is my connection going on? Maybe it's
the Docker Hub rate limit in a
The connection is pretty fast. I wouldn't expect
the 25 meg fail to slow me down.
Okay.
Come on. I'm impatient.
Gonna start pulling all these images out of
the fence.
Alright.
So well, let's let's think about what this
is actually saying, though. Right? Because it's, like,
the default command
in a container. Like, somebody in the chat
is saying to remove the command, and we
should just use the default, which is totally
valid. But But then it could take us
there for a reason. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. What's what's a little confusing is the
how would you change that mount point
to, like, remove like, if this is the
upstream
Cilium,
like, the upstream Cilium image,
how have how have you managed to remove
the default command?
All that I wonder if they've
added any do wanna edit that daemon set
again? I wonder if they've added any volume,
man. That would just make that That's what
I was that that's kinda what I was
trying to yeah. K edit d s Manasen
Cilium
and Cilium. Right?
That's for volume.
Account type.
All you might mount.
No
root there, is there?
Oh, wait. This is the command. It's not
the entry point.
Change command to entry point.
Like that? Uh-huh.
I think that's it.
Nope.
No. No. We can print it. It says
command command and Rx. Yeah. Yeah. That's what
I yeah. That's
Okay.
Where's the entry point gone?
There we go.
Goddamn it. Why is my
Yeah. You So this should be this is
this should be command. Right?
Yeah. That was just me being silly.
The audience is suggesting the command shouldn't start
with a slash.
I I don't think that's a problem. Feel
like I don't think I I I think
it is a problem. I'm with the audience.
So I'm gonna edit this and
see what happens.
Container error.
Alright. Do you wanna get the logs out
of that again then?
Yeah. That doesn't change anything. It's still Script
is still in the root directory. It's still
called init. Is it called init I'm gonna
copy this verbatim. Hold on.
Copy.
I'm gonna go over to here.
Assuming it worked, it didn't crash.
Yeah. I got zero.
Why is it not working here? Like, what
could what could cause that?
Let's put that back because
it made it worse. So We could remove
the inner container and hope there's not needed.
But
I think it will be.
But I don't think that's the fix.
Slash inner
Okay.
Init container on.
It must be. So suggested we could always
have command as bash and then r x
dash c slash, and I can do that.
I mean, but there's a I'm not convinced
that's a problem because there is a Shebang
fail. Although, assuming
is there a?
I mean, the only way that I can
think of to override to, like, to move
like, this is the upstream one eight five
Cilium
container.
The only way that I can think of
to remove that in a container
from the root file system is to mount
a volume over the top of it.
And
we don't see any volumes in the demon
set. Oh, well, what if you what if
they sorry.
Pre pill the image, and then the pill
policy on it is is not present.
The image could be a random image.
That's a great point.
Image
pull
poll.
I have not present. Not present. I set
it to always. There we go.
Do you wanna use the oh, wait. We're
running out of time. Do you wanna use
a Vim? You wanna do that? Because I
I'm I'm out of this VIM.
Yeah.
Done. Oh, okay.
Oh, look at that.
That was very
Sticky. Yeah. So, I mean, if you
pre like you say, you pre pulled the
image and then
modify the remove the inner container on the
on the image.
That's really, really mean. So Yeah. For all
we know that image, it's all time retagged
or something.
We fixed it. We're two minutes over, but
we've What?
Two minutes over. I feel like that's a
victory. I
do feel like that we got there in
the end. We went off on the wrong
direction to begin with and then got there
in the end. Yeah.
Nicely done, of course. That that was good.
It's one of those things, like, you have
a moment of clarity,
you could you just don't think about it.
That that was that was good. Two really
good problems there.
And you're just checking if can if we
can run stuff. I'm just checking if we
can I I I I I I know
over time, but I feel like I can
I'm not gonna sleep tonight if I don't
actually try and run a bot? So
there is a crash loop back off happening,
but it's Seth
and who needs storage in a Oh, no.
Seth takes Seth will take a lot of
time to get help. Yeah.
There we go. It's running. Excellent.
Okay.
Nice. Alright. That's the I think I think
we got there.
Yeah.
Thank you to all of our breakers. Not
not
to Matt. Really, I'm just thanking Akash. Those
were some
good problems, actually. And
it's really I mean, it's difficult, right, when
you're staring at this and you're trying to
work it out and just feel a bit
of pressure. Easy if you go down rabbit
holes. And I think we had a few,
but I'm really really happy. I think we
did really well there. That was great. Oh,
you did. Yeah. And when we got we
got two working clusters. It's a team effort.
We got two working clusters at the end,
and
I learned about container d. When I was
doing this a year ago,
the the default,
you know, image container runner was was Docker.
So I've learned a lot about container d
today. So I feel like I come away
with something.
Alright.
Lee, thank you. That was awesome. We did
it. We fixed it.
Well, it's got a good comment. You could
change your background now. Everything is fine. We
have actually Yes. Absolutely.
Yeah. I can change it to,
you know, me on vacation, I guess.
Nice.
Alright. Well, thank you again, Lee. Enjoy your
vacation. We will be back next week with
more clustered. Have a good time, everyone. Bye.
Thanks, everyone.